September 1984 at around midnight a ship
named Valhalla sailed out of Boston's
Harbor on board were several tons of
rifles shotguns ammunition grenades and
bulletproof vests the mission get these
weapons to the Irish Republican Army or
IRA in Ireland as soon as possible the
IRA was a paramilitary organization
fighting for Ireland's independence from
the British and the person who sent this
armed shipment to the IRA a man named
James Whitey Bulger Boston's most
notorious Crime Boss
the story of James Whitey Bulger is
insane Not only was he a ruthless killer
but he was a ruthless killer that had
the protection of the FBI
a decade earlier Wadi had made the
sweetheart deal of the century with the
FBI Whitey was supposed to provide the
FBI with Insider information about the
Italian mafia who both Whitey and the
FBI wanted to take down and in exchange
the FBI wouldn't go after him that was
how this deal was supposed to go but in
reality it was more like the FBI was
protecting Whitey Bulger as he killed
off his enemies and took over Boston
they shoot at him from investigations by
local police they let him know when
someone was about to rat on him so he
could take care of that person basically
this Crime Boss had the FBI in his own
Pockets while he was allowed to run his
criminal Enterprise as he pleased and
with all this protection by the FBI he
thought he could get away with
International arms trafficking too
to pay for the weapons him and his
associates exported hundreds of
thousands of dollars from local drug
dealers with the weapons in hand now all
they had to do was get them across the
Atlantic Ocean without getting caughts
the plan was to have the Valhalla ship
transfer the weapons to another ship
along the way and then returned to
Boston but things didn't go as planned
thanks to a tip-off the Irish Navy
caught the second ship off the Irish
coast and the weapons were seized and
the Valhalla it headed back to Boston
straight into the hands of custom
officials
they immediately began interrogating the
crew and Whitey's eyes something wasn't
right
how did the Irish Navy know exactly
where and when to catch the ship and how
did they know what was on board there
was only one possibility
a rat and Whitey's eyes went straight to
one man John McIntyre a mechanic and
Drug Smuggler that was a part of the
Valhalla ship if John McIntyre did
indeed rat Whitey outs why do you deal
with the FBI could be in Jeopardy
running a gang was one thing but
supplying a designated terrorist
organization with weapons that would be
something not even the FBI would be able
to protect Whitey from
so Whitey and his crew lured McIntyre
out with a party invitation to their
house once he arrived they dropped into
the basement chain him to a chair and
then the interrogation began
I think you're a rat are you a rat
Johnny why do you asked McIntyre and
what a devious smile on his face why do
you begin breaking the man's fingers one
by one until he finally confessed yes
McIntyre did in fact tell the cops
everything about the Valhalla and the
weapons he apologized for being so weak
and begged for forgiveness but it was
too late
after a few hours of torture Wadi asked
him you want a bullet in the head unable
to go through another round of torture
McIntyre nodded and why he shot him
Point Blank ending his misery
his crew dug a hole buried the body and
went home and that was just the
beginning of Whitey's murderous Rampage
but none of this was the shocking Parts
the shocking part is that when Whitey
Bulger was in his 20s he never killed or
tortured anyone he was just an ambitious
Hustler trying to make money on the
streets but that all changed when Whitey
Bulger was sent to prison where he went
through an extremely traumatic events
a traumatic event so extreme that it
broke him down and took him to quote the
depths of insanity End quotes
and when he finally came out of it he
was no longer the man he once was now he
was a ruthless cold-blooded killer
what sort of traumatic event turns a man
into a complete psychopath like this
while in prison James Whitey Bulger was
a part of the caa's project MK otra
where the CIA drugged and tortured their
test subjects all in the name of Mind
Control yes one of America's most
notorious Killers was a product of the
nation's very own intelligence agency
my name is Jake Tran I make
documentaries on money power war and
crime on my team subscribe for more if
you want to win a thousand dollars cash
all you have to do is follow me on
Instagram Jake Tran and you're
automatically entered a few of you have
won already watch out for fake accounts
I would never message you asking for
money or to invest and this is Whitey
Bulger Boston's most notorious Crime
Boss
[Music]
if Buddy Bulger were still in business
today he would be taking his online
security extremely seriously and for
good reason but you definitely don't
need to be a criminal to take your
online security seriously
your personal information is littered
all around the internet it is everywhere
and data Brokers love to take advantage
of that by selling your data to the
highest bidder all without you ever
knowing about it the problem is that the
more your data is sold off the higher
the chance that you'll be a victim of a
data breach and it's way more common
than you think in 2021 over 100 million
Android users had their personal
information leaked that same year 93 of
the users on LinkedIn also have their
personal details for sale online after a
data breach so if it can happen to these
giant companies that we all know it can
definitely happen to all the random
businesses your data Brokers sell your
info to and when it does happen your
phone named social security number
spending habits and even your home
address is up for grabs without you ever
knowing about it and even though you
have the right to request data Brokers
to delete your info it can literally
take years thankfully that is where
Incognito comes in incognee reaches out
to data Brokers on your behalf and gets
them to remove your personal data to
protect your privacy and it's all
automated here is how it works first
create an account and give incoming need
some info about yourself then you want
to Grant incognate the right to work for
you so they can contact the data Brokers
on your behalf and then boom sit back
relax and Incognito will take it from
there they'll deal with the data Brokers
and keep you updated on their progress
every step of the way it's really that
easy to protect yourself and your
family's privacy and right now the first
100 people to use the code Jake Tran
with the link below will get 20 off
incogniti so pause the video and go to
incognito.com with the link below to get
20 off for the first 100 people thanks
to incognito for sponsoring this video
nicknamed Whitey due to his blonde hair
Whitey came from the projects in South
Boston locally known as Southie Southie
was more or less an isolated Irish
ghetto as a teenager Woody began to
build his reputation as a thief and
Street Fighter and it wasn't long before
he got into trouble with the law at just
14 years old Bulger was arrested for the
first time for stealing but instead of
being scared straight he just became
more determined to live a life of crime
after a failed armed robbery while he
was sent to a juvenile detention center
but even they failed to straighten him
out Whitey was a die-hard Southie and he
knew the only way to make it in South
Boston was to get to the top of the
criminal underworld but then in a
strange turn of events Whitey joins the
Air Force at age 20. maybe he thought he
could get out of crime and make a name
for himself doing something good
something legal but no matter how hard
he tried he simply couldn't hide his
violent streak after getting into
several fights why do you spend time in
the military prison and was later
arrested again for going absent without
leave after only three years his career
in the Air Force was over
Whitey was backward all started back on
the streets of South Boston but this
time he wouldn't try to do anything
better with his life no no no this time
he would stick to what he was good at
crime and as expected or white he went
the cops in jail time were never far
behind in 1956 at just 27 years old
Whitey was arrested and sentenced to
several years in prison for armed
robbery of a bank and a Truck hijacking
it was Whitey's first time in federal
prison and in 1959 he even got
transferred to Alcatraz the infamous
Maximum Security Prison in the San
Francisco Bay
and it was here that Whitey was first
approached by the CIA offered a reduced
sentence for joining some vaguely
explained experiment Whitey didn't think
twice about what he was about to get
into but it would become a choice that
haunted him for the rest of his life
[Music]
it was at the height of the Cold War and
the USSR in America were throwing
everything they had at each other
besides going to full-on physical war
and one of the tactics America accused
the Soviets of using in this war was
mind control Yes you heard that right
mind control the CIA believed the
Soviets had figured out a way to turn
everyday people into a motionless
thoughtless puppets that would do
anything they told them to but instead
of being horrified by the idea the CIA
was more intrigued they wanted to know
if they could do the same thing
themselves enter MK Ultra
cia's darkest projects ever
basically the scientists behind MK Ultra
would test all sorts of drugs and
torture techniques on as many people as
they could they would try to figure out
what combination of these chemicals in
psychological or physical abuse would
create a completely controllable puppet
because one of their objectives was to
turn their victims into a so-called
Manchurian Candidate a programmed killer
who would kill on command without any
remorse and forget about it a moment
later someone who would say whatever
they wanted them to even if it meant
they would go to jail or be killed
themselves the CIA tested its program on
everyone from its own officers to
mentally ill hospital patients and of
course they tested it on prisoners all
they had to do was offer a prisoner A
reduced sentence and he'd agree to
almost anything plus who better to turn
into a Mindless killer to take on the
Soviets than someone already prone to
violence and that's where Whitey Bulger
came in the CIA came to whitey while he
was in Alcatraz and told him that they
were looking for a cure for
schizophrenia in exchange for joining
the program and helping test the
treatment he would get reduced jail time
but it was all a lie instead the CIA
used psychological torture and LSD to
destabilize Whitey's psyche they
literally took a violent criminal and
forced him through a brainwashing
program Whitey later said that they took
him to quote the depths of insanity end
quote Joe how about Whitey Bulger oh
yeah bro that's FBI no no no
really he was MK Ultra what does that
mean didn't he have a deal he was in
Alcatraz and they were like hey this is
for schizophrenia we're testing this
drug this is gonna it will lessen your
time if you do oh I didn't know that oh
my God jurora who helped convict Crime
Boss Whitey Bulger feels guilty after
learning he was in MK Ultra holy [ __ ]
Whitey Bulger wrote to a juror who
convinced him that he would be dosed
with LSD monitored by a physician and
repeatedly asked leading questions like
would you ever kill anyone no over 50
times in 19 65 after having served 9
years in jail Whitey was set free but
something deep inside him had changed he
wasn't just an ambitious criminal
anymore oh no MK Ultra had turned him
into something else entirely it had
turned him into a heartless killer
[Music]
in the 1960s Boston was dominated by
several rival gangs the Italian mafia
controlled the North End district and
the Irish gangs were in Somerville and
Charlestown they fought over turf
control of local businesses loan
sharking gambling and the growing drug
Market
after his release from Alcatraz what he
fell right back in with his old crowd
and became a debt collector for the
killing gang an irish-american gang that
had dominated South Boston for over 20
years it was during a local gang war
that Whitey committed his first murder
his Target was a member of the rival
gang but in a crazy case of mistaken
identity Whitey ended up shooting the
target's twin brother instead after
realizing his mistake what he panicked
and raced to tell his mentor and fellow
mobster's house what he told him
everything that had happened but the man
didn't seem too concerned he just said
quote don't worry about it he wasn't
healthy anyway he smoked he would have
gotten lung cancer end quote with a gang
member's brother dead the mob War
escalated quickly in just a few days
Donald Colleen the boss of Whitey's gang
was also dead something would have to be
done to stop the Bloodshed where both
gangs would probably go extinct there
was only one way to sort things out
though and that meant the leaders of the
rival gangs would have to sit down and
and talk it out they chose a Boston
nightclub as their venue keep the peace
between the two sides a man named Howie
winter was asked to mediate Howie was
the leader of the Winter Hill Gang
Boston's biggest Irish mob after hours
of talking the dispute was finally
settled but the gangs went even one step
further instead of heading back to their
separate operations they decided to join
forces with Howie winter as their boss
with Boston's biggest Irish mob on his
side Whitey Bulger quickly took control
of Southeast criminal underworld he and
his associates began shaking down all
the neighborhoods bookmakers and Loan
Sharks and they had a pretty sneaky
tactic to extort money from people first
they would create a problem then they
offered the solution they would smash
restaurants and bars and the next day
shocked by the tragic events they would
offer protection so it would never
happen again they would go up to people
and tell them listen so and so want you
dead they offered us a hundred thousand
dollars to kill you but if you pay us
first we'll leave leave you alone and
they always paid
soon many of these Mobsters were
swimming in money and many of them like
to party and have a good time but Whitey
Bulger wasn't one of them maybe it was
the after effects of MK Ultra or maybe
he had just always been that way but why
he just didn't seem to know how to
interact with people on a human level as
a result he was rarely seen at fancy
parties or clubs for him it was all
about business he never lost sight of
that one clear goal he had in mind to
become Boston's Undisputed Crime Boss
people
[Music]
[Music]
during the 1970s one of the FBI's top
priorities was to bust the Italian mafia
in Boston but to do that they would need
help from the inside they would need
someone who could tell them exactly what
was happening and when and who better to
ask than Whitey Bulger he was connected
to Boston's biggest gangs and he was as
dirty as they come if the FBI promised
him a good deal a chance to stay out of
jail for whatever he was currently busy
with maybe he would agree besides Whitey
had a difficult relationship with the
Italian mob as the leader of the Irish
Winter Hill Gang Howie winter had always
done his best to keep peace with the
Italian mafia he simply didn't want to
step on their toes but Whitey hated the
fact that everyone had to cater to the
Italians he wanted to shake the status
quo so in 1975 Whitey secretly met with
an FBI agent named John Connolly
Connolly grew up in the same South
Boston housing project as Whitey so they
immediately had a special connection
during their meeting Asian Connolly
asked why if he could provide the FBI
with information to bust the Italian mob
Connolly told him that the mafia was
already doing the same thing to him so
why not Fight Fire with Fire here was
Whitey's chance to take down his Rivals
and get into the FBI's good graces there
was just one problem the unwritten law
of the mob was that you must never
cooperate with the police or the feds in
Boston informants had a pretty short
life expectancy once people knew you
were a rat you were done if you were
lucky your criminal career was simply
over but more often than not you would
end up dead and buried under a bridge
and as a rule Whitey hated nothing more
than rats if he was going to work with
the FBI he was going to do it under one
clear condition he would not be an
informant but a secret strategist agent
Connolly agreed
shortly after what he became a part of
the FBI's top Echelon program and for
him it was a gift to send from heaven
for one he could use the FBI to bring
down his major rival the Italian mafia
he would provide them with the
information and the FBI would do all the
dirty work for him but the best part was
that he would be protected from any
current or future investigations as part
of the top Echelon program the FBI
shielded their informants from the local
police to keep them in the game sawadi's
informant status gave him virtual
immunity from now on he could run his
criminal Empire as he pleased and he
wasted no time taking advantage of this
fact
foreign
[Music]
by the late 1970s only Howie winter
stands in Whitey's way to becoming
Boston's biggest strongest Crime Boss
and Winter's luck is running out in 1979
winter organized a race fixing scheme at
the horse tracks his gang would bribe
jockeys and dope horses to get the
results they wanted but then one jockey
got caught and spilled the beans to the
police as a result winter was arrested
together with several members of his
inner circle Whitey had also been part
of the race fixing scheme but thanks to
his FBI Handler John Connolly and he
charges against Whitey were immediately
dropped with his former boss in prison
Whitey and another mobster Stephen
flemmy stepped into the power vacuum and
took over the winter Hill Gang as the
leader of the Irish mob and with the FBI
taking down his Italian Rivals one by
one what he's business was booming loan
sharking truck hijacking arms
trafficking extortion his gang had a
hand in everything
but then people started getting a little
suspicious every time the local police
tried to open a case against Whiting
they would come to a dead end when they
asked the FBI about him they were simply
told that Whitey was only a small time
criminal no one to worry about in return
for FBI protection Whitey made a big
show of giving them information on the
Italian mafia but in reality agent
Connolly and the FBI were Whitey's
informants not the other way around
not only do they block any attempts by
the local police to investigate them
they also told him when someone was
about to rat on him so he could handle
the situation he was simply untouchable
then in September 1983 the FBI finally
scored a major victory against Boston's
organized crime
with Whitey's help they arrested Jerry
and julo the leader of the Italian mafia
when the FBI arrested him during dinner
at a fancy restaurant he famously
shouted quote I'll be back before my
pork chops get cold end quote instead he
was sentenced to 45 years in prison
local Chief Jerry anjulo is jailed for a
staggering 45 years on assorted charges
of racketeering but the leader of the
Italian mafia in jail and complete
protection thanks to the FBI Whitey
Bulger and his winter Hill Gang now had
complete control of Boston's underworld
Whitey had gotten what he always wanted
Boston belonged to him now it was time
to rule his Empire with an iron fist
when Whitey Bulger helped ship the
weapons to the IRA he took a big risk if
they caught him not even the deal with
the FBI could protect him anymore we're
talking about smuggling weapons to
foreign countries after all but next to
his career as an international arms
dealer Whitey took another big risk
expanding his drug business drug dealers
weren't exactly the type of criminals
you could trust with your life
if they got caught they've ran out
everyone to save their own skin but the
bigger problem was that Whitey was
challenging another Federal agency the
DEA and just like with the weapons if
the DEA could link Whitey to the drug
trade his FBI informant status wouldn't
protect him anymore and it wasn't long
before the DEA agents found someone
willing to talk a South Boston Street
dealer had lost a huge amount of money
in a failed drug deal and could no
longer pay Whitey for his product
fearing for his life the dealer began to
talk to the feds the result more than 50
of Whitey's Associates got arrested in
an instant Whitey's drug business was
done and the DEA was hot on this Trail
luckily thanks to FBI agent Connolly why
do you manage to stay out of jail agent
Connolly argued that Whitey was still a
valuable source for the FBI but this
excuse was slowly wearing thin more and
more police officers and federal agents
began asking questions about the deal
white he had with the FBI was he
actually a valuable Source or was it in
in fact a corrupt deal between Whitey
and a few FBI agents agent Connolly had
grown to like Whitey and even stole
reports from other informants and put
Whitey's name on them to make him look
like a legit source but soon their deal
would come to an end in 1990 agent
Connolly retired from the FBI and
Whitey's informant status was terminated
for the federal prosecutors and State
Police that meant one thing it was
finally time to take down Whitey Bulger
thanks to Whitey's murdering spree
racking up 11 kills in his time as a
Boston mobster several bookmakers were
happy to testify against him and
hopefully save their own lives in the
process and so a federal case was built
against him in December 1994 agent
Connolly warned his old friend one last
time the feds are coming for you it's
time to leave town a few days later
Whitey Bulger fled Boston and went into
hiding
[Music]
thanks to agent John Connolly Whitey
Bulger and his Irish mob had enjoyed
exclusive protection by the FBI for over
15 years for them the deal with what he
turned out to be the most embarrassing
mistake in FBI history it was corruption
at the highest level of a federal agency
they had let Whitey and his Pals get
away with literal murder all in the name
of collecting information on the Italian
mafia and in the process they simply
helped the Irish mob take their place
with agent Connolly retired and Whitey
Bulger on the run it was time for
Redemption but if they thought they
could catch Whitey by surprise they were
badly mistaken he had planned his Escape
for years he created a whole new
identity for himself complete with an ID
and credit cards in his new name he even
had cash jewelry and passports stored in
safety boxes all over the U.S and Europe
he had always said you had to be ready
to take off on short notice and when the
time came Whitey was more than ready for
the FBI it was as if Whitey had dropped
off the face of the Earth over the years
they received tips that people had
spotted him from all over the world
including London and Italy at one point
FBI agents even went to Uruguay to
investigate a lead but they simply
couldn't find him Whitey Bulger had
become a ghost meanwhile Whitey's former
FBI contact John Connolly had to face
criminal charges himself it turned out
that some of the tip-offs he had given
Whitey over the years had led to murder
so he was convicted of second-degree
murder and sentenced to 40 year years in
prison but just to make things a bit
more difficult for the FBI Connolly
decided not to testify against Whitey so
even though the FBI had Connolly and his
other associates arrested they still had
no idea where to find Whitey and there
was a good reason for that not only did
he keep a super low profile and avoided
any criminal activity but the FBI also
didn't have any good pictures of him
that they could show to the public sure
they had some surveillance footage in a
few old mug shots but what he was now
over 70 years old so all these old
pictures weren't that helpful and so
Whitey went dark for 16 years
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
Carol Gasko seemed like your regular
friendly old couple next door enjoying
their retirement in a small apartment in
Santa Monica California Charlie spent
most of his time watching TV while Carol
would go for walks or visit the farmers
market exactly how would you expect a
normal 80-something-year-old couple to
spend their days their landlord
described them as the perfect tenants
they never complained and always paid
rent on time and in cash but some
neighbors were a little suspicious of
Charlie he would often wear a hat and
sunglasses to hide his face when he left
the apartment and when Carol talked too
long with other people he would yell at
them and tell them to get lost this went
way past an old guy being anti-social
Charlie couldn't seem to stand the
company of strangers to make matters
worse at night the neighbors were often
spot Charlie staring through his
apartment Window with binoculars yes
something about Charlie and Carol was
definitely off but the weirdest thing
about Charlie and Carol every day a
piece of paper with the instructions
please do not knock would appear stuck
to their apartment door in their good
reasons for that because Charlie and
Carol Gasco the friendly couple next
door were not who they said they were
strange grumpy old man's name wasn't
even Charlie it was Whitey James Whitey
Bulger America's most notorious Crime
Boss
Carol his sweet friendly wife she wasn't
who she said she was either her real
name was Catherine Gregg and she had
been Whitey's girlfriend for long before
he retired in Santa Monica while the FBI
tried to catch Whitey for 16 years he
had been hiding in plain sight in a
modest apartment in California but his
luck would soon run out after years of
chasing false leaves the FBI decided to
try a new strategy instead of looking
for Whitey they could try to find him
through his girlfriend Catherine Gray
since Whitey had disappeared no one had
seen or heard from her so the FBI
assumed they were on the run together
and in Catherine's case they had
something they could work with like most
mob wives and girlfriends Catherine had
gotten several plastic surgeries done so
the FBI reached out to plastic surgeons
all around Boston and it wasn't long
before they got a call from a doctor who
had found her files suddenly the FBI had
a treasure Trove of high quality
pictures of Whitey's girlfriend
Catherine
shortly after the FBI announced this new
search Target in 14 cities and doubled
the reward for her capture to a hundred
thousand dollars and it worked just one
day after the announcement the FBI
received several messages saying that
the woman they were looking for was
Carol Gasko and that she was living in
Santa Monica with her husband Charlie a
database search revealed that Charlie
and Carol Gasco were basically Ghosts no
driver's license no California IDs apart
from a name and a social security number
it was as if they didn't exist the FBI
was positive they had found their man
and a short surveillance operation later
it was confirmed after 16 years they
finally had Whitey Bulger and his
girlfriend Catherine right in front of
them it was time to strike but instead
of storming their apartment with guns
blazing they decided to set a trap on
June 22nd 2011 at around 5 45 PM the
building manager called Whitey's
apartment to tell them that someone had
broken into their Locker in the basement
someone had to come down to check what
was missing Catherine replied that her
husband would come down in a minute in
his prime Whitey would have smelled the
trap a mile away but what he was now 81
years old and this time his criminal
instincts failed him when Whitey arrived
in the basement FBI agents immediately
took him down
surprisingly he offered no resistance he
even confirmed that he was in fact
Whitey Bulger during a search of his
apartment a little later the Asians
found eight hundred thousand dollars in
cash and more than 30 weapons including
rifles and shotguns plus several fake
IDs
[Music]
[Music]
in November 2013 Whitey Bulger was
sentenced to two life sentences plus
five years for extortion drug
trafficking and at least 11 murders
first four years he served time in a
prison in Florida but on October 29 2018
he was transferred to a prison in West
Virginia less than 12 hours later he was
found dead
several inmates had beaten him to death
with padlocks wrapped in socks the
guards found him with his eyes and
tongue nearly entirely ripped out and
one guard described Whitey as quote
unrecognizable end quote
after Whitey's death many wondered why
he wasn't transferred to a prison with
better protection some believe he was
deliberately sent to his death
one of the suspects is an Italian mafia
Hitman was serving a life sentence in
jail if he was involved he would have a
clear motive killing the man who ratted
out the Italian mafia
notorious mobster James Whitey Bulger
was found dead earlier this week at a
prison in West Virginia a convicted
Mafia Hitman who once lived in West
Springfield is a prime suspect
unfortunately the spa where Whitey
Bulger died was conveniently not covered
by surveillance cameras and the inmates
involved they stand firm by their
anti-rap beliefs to this day the truth
behind the murder of Boston's most
notorious Crime Boss remains a mystery
Whitey Bulger was one of the most
ruthless Mobsters in U.S history but
even though he had a criminal streak
from the beginning he never tortured or
killed anyone in his 20s that all
changed after he was pressured to join
the cia's MK Ultra program in jail in a
private letter Whitey later said that
the CIA appealed to our sense of doing
something worthwhile for society but
that was just a false promise to lure
him into the program after he joined
MKUltra the CIA dosed Whitey at least 50
times with mind-altering drugs like LSD
Whitey later said we experienced
horrible periods of living nightmares
and even blood coming out of the walls
during the most extreme hallucinations
they would ask him again and again would
you ever kill anyone
all the psychological torture left
Whitey traumatized for the rest of his
life
talking about all the details of MK
Ultra the psychological torture the LSD
experiments and all the illegal
brainwashing was beyond the scope of
this video besides the Vivid details of
torture would trigger all kinds of red
flags with the YouTube algorithm luckily
we've released a deep dive into every
dark evil secret MK Ultra holds as a
private documentary available only to
members of this Channel and they have
been loving the documentary all you have
to do to get access to this video on MK
Ultra right now and all the other
documentary length videos they're too
controversial too dark too risky to post
publicly is click the join button below
once you sign up you'll get exclusive
access to MK Ultra the CIA coup in Iran
the bin Laden papers every jepstein and
many more including the upcoming one of
the CIA black sites even we are worried
about publishing these are the things
they should be teaching you in
University about how the world works but
unlike University you get all of this
for just five dollars a month
and there's a refund policy too unlike
most YouTube memberships so if you join
and you don't think it's worth it email
us within your first month of joining
and we will personally refund you for
your first month after your first month
there is no refund so scroll down and
hit that join button now
[Music]
it's about Whitey Bulger and a super
good so I'm really happy I finally got
to make a video on this let me know what
you guys thought in the comments below
and if you're new here this is one of
the biggest channels on YouTube for
documentaries on money power war and
crime we make multiple documentaries
just like this one every single week for
free so if you like this one click the
Subscribe button below remember you can
follow me on Instagram for a chance to
win a thousand dollars at Jake Tran and
if you're on Facebook and you watch
shorter videos you can follow our page
over there that's going to wrap it up
stay dangerous out there and I'll see
you guys in the next one
[Music]
thank you